SARAH D'ANGELO: Hi, everyone.
Thanks for joining us today.
We're going to be talking
about Cloud Native Development
in the IDE with Cloud Code.
I'm Sarah.
I'm a user experience
researcher on Google Cloud.
IVAN PORTYANKIN: And I'm Ivan.
And I'm a software engineer
on Cloud Code team.
SARAH D'ANGELO: And
today we're going
to talk to you about
Cloud Native Development.
We'll introduce Cloud Code, our
plugin for Visual Studio code
and JetBrains IDEs.
Ivan's going to demo some
great Kubernetes and Cloud Run
workflows using Cloud Code.
We'll talk about some additional
Cloud Code features for you
to explore on your own time,
and we'll wrap things up
really quickly.
So let's get started.
Ivan, what is Cloud
Native Development?
IVAN PORTYANKIN: So when
we talk about Cloud Native
we can discuss the
six major principles.
First, we build everything
as microservices.
So instead of big
[INAUDIBLE] applications
split into small
microservices, which
use different technologies
for those microservices.
We track them separately
in source repositories.
And we can scale
them granularly.
Second, everything
should be code.
This way we can track this code,
we can roll back this code,
and see the version of change.
This includes source code, test
code, and automation scripts.
Third, everything now should
be billed as containers.
Within a container image you
can include all dependencies
and tools that you
need and focus on code
itself, and not worry about
system incompatibilities
[INAUDIBLE] complex.
Fourth is we need automation.
Since we split our system
into small microservices,
complexity went up.
And we need to take
care of moving pieces
by using [INAUDIBLE] integration
system, building on each
commit to make sure integration
runs, and all pieces,
moving pieces, and
microservices are well
tested against each other.
Fifth is declarative approach.
So for Kubernetes, the
system state is complicated.
So instead of scripts,
we write a YAML
where we describe the
state of the system.
The desired state in Kubernetes
drives the system to that state
and takes care of it.
And sixth and last,
scalable system.
In Kubernetes
world, it means you
can scale your microservices
running as a single deployment
to multiple replicates.
In a serverless system
it's even more important
you pay for what you use.
You pay on demand.
So whenever you have a
request, we can burst up
or burst down your
deployment, and make sure
we can serve your resources.
SARAH D'ANGELO: And there are
essentially two approaches
for Cloud Native Development.
We have Kubernetes
and serverless.
And it really boils
down to how much
control you want over the
stack, versus how much you want
to focus on the business logic.
Serverless is
incredibly powerful,
and it lets you
focus on the business
logic of your
application by providing
a higher level of abstraction.
Kubernetes, on the
other hand, gives you
a higher granularity and control
over the stack implementation.
And whichever one you choose,
we've got you covered.
Google provides end to end
tooling for both serverless
and Kubernetes.
In this talk, we're going
to focus on Cloud Code.
So it'll be centering on the
coding part of this journey.
So what is Cloud Code?
Cloud Code is our IDE plugin
for Visual Studio code
and JetBrains IDEs.
And our goal with
Cloud Code is to really
make your inner development
[INAUDIBLE] easy.
We're going to speed up
your development experience,
simplify local development,
extend the production
deployments, and allow you to
debug, deploy applications,
all from in your IDE.
And we understand
that developers
have many different
workflows, and Cloud Code
can support you wherever
you are in your journey.
Whether it's getting started
with easy to use templates,
migrating your application
to Kubernetes, editing
an existing Cloud Run or
Kubernetes application,
or containerizing
application, we've
got you covered with a lot of
great features and resources
with Cloud Code.
So let's dive right
in and show you
how to use Cloud Code with
your Kubernetes workflows.
Ivan's going to show us how to
use Cloud Code to containerize
an application, deploy
to remote cluster,
debug a running
application, view resources,
and stream logs all using
Cloud Code in his IDE.
So take it away, Ivan.
IVAN PORTYANKIN: Let's use
Cloud Code and IntelliJ
IDEA to develop and debug
a small Java Springboard
Microservice application
on Google Kubernetes engine
cluster.
Thus, let's go Configure,
Preferences, Plugins,
and make sure we have
Cloud Code installed.
I do have it installed here.
But if you don't,
you can also go
to Marketplace, type
Cloud Code, and easily
find it here in the list.
Perfect.
So once we click OK
and have it installed,
we can start working with
our Kubernetes applications.
An easy way to start is to
click Create New Project,
and select one of
the quick start
templates that we
provide for Cloud Code.
Let's select Java Hello
World for this simple demo
and click Next.
For the cluster, you can store
it in multiple locations.
You can use Docker Hub,
but most of the time,
it depends on the
cluster that you use.
For Google Kubernetes
Engine, we're
going to be using Google
Container Image Registry
and that most of the time
will be preferable for us.
So once we enter the name and
location, we're ready to go.
So click Finish.
But I also have my configured
project already done.
So I'll just open it from here.
Let's take a look what
we have in this project.
Just let's open the readme file.
And let's see what
type of project it is.
So this could be a simple Java
Springboard application running
a simple HTTP server,
returning a stream,
and will be running
Kubernetes cluster.
Deployment will contain a new
application, which will run it
as a [INAUDIBLE],, and
it will communicate
to the outside world with a
service type load balancer.
Description of the Kubernetes
manifests are located here.
And as you can see, Cloud
Code will provide you
a very nice helper
text, changes, or even
some sort of a linting example.
If I'm mistaken
here in that field,
Cloud Code will tell me that
is not the correct type,
and expecting an integer,
[INAUDIBLE] replicates
[INAUDIBLE] correct.
So we can use Cloud Code
to edit our YAML files,
but let's go to the
source code next.
So we have a simple
Springboard application.
Look at this
familiar annotation.
And spring boot controller.
It just returns hello world
with double exclamation mark,
and we are ready to go
and deploy to Kubernetes.
But how do we do
it from our IDE?
Let's take a look at
the run configurations.
Cloud Code provided as
two run configuration
towards Kubernetes.
So the first one is
run on Kubernetes
who will just build
your image and deploy it
to Kubernetes cluster.
How does it build?
We can take a look here at
Build and Deploy Settings.
The build settings will give
you a list of the images we
are building in this project.
So if you can
select an image, you
can see the build
is currently is jib.
Jib is a plugin from
Maven and Gradle
that builds your Java images
really fast and really
efficient.
But we can also
select other options.
Docker file is
[INAUDIBLE] this project.
So that's a standard way
of building your images.
If you want to maintain, you
want to write a Docker file,
you can do that.
As you can see, we have this
jib Maven plugin configured,
and it's already selected.
And we also have build backs.
Build backs is a great
way to build an image
for your new project if you
don't want to create a Docker
file, or you don't
want to use jib,
or maybe it's not
a Java project.
Build backs will use most
common build systems,
detects them, builds, and
optimize the image for you
based on that build
system and project.
So let's leave the
selection as it is with jib.
And [INAUDIBLE] this was run.
So let's check
develop of Kubernetes.
The only difference
would be this setting.
On develop in Kubernetes we will
automatically rebuild and rerun
your changes.
Cloud Code will check if you
do any changes in the code,
in your test code, or maybe
in your Kubernetes YAML files.
Automatically rebuild the
image, tag it, push it, and make
cluster update its workflows.
And it's really what we call
inner development [INAUDIBLE],,
which makes the user IDE the
ultimate tool to ideally debug
and develop your application
right on your Kubernetes
cluster.
Let's see if it's
going to work this way.
Let's quick run.
In the meanwhile, there's
a two window [INAUDIBLE]
Cloud Code called
Kubernetes Explorer.
If you open it, you can see we
can easily list our [INAUDIBLE]
and deployments.
So let's see here in Output.
It seems like we already
had the image in cash.
So it's a bit [INAUDIBLE].
And manifests have
been deployed.
Cloud Code also provides a very
helpful advance in event log.
So we can see where we
deployed, what context was used.
Deploy was completed
successfully.
And now, we have this link
to open our application.
Hello world with the
exclamation mark.
Perfect.
And we also can use Explorer
to get some more information.
We can describe.
We can stream logs, if we
don't have the logs available,
or [INAUDIBLE] terminal,
copyright source name,
or even view remote
YAML and compare it
to all existing YAML.
For example, if we
choose describe in
our just deployed path, we
can see the statuses, events,
tolerations, volumes,
conditions, and everything
we need to know about how
our application is being
run on our Kubernetes cluster.
OK, but what if I don't
like this exclamation mark?
What if I want four
exclamation marks?
Let's do that.
I write four, and let's
see what's going on.
It looks like Cloud Code was
able to detect this change.
It checks the change.
It builds the image.
We can see the Maven
build is running.
It's successful.
It tags.
It pushes the image,
as you can see.
Paths were just updated.
Old [INAUDIBLE] was removed,
and new one deployed.
So hopefully the change is now
live in our Kubernetes cluster.
And it is live.
We have four exclamation
marks in our demo page.
This is amazing.
So we can continue
making changes
to our code we YAML files.
Cloud Code will listen
to those changes
and automatically build a new
image, push it to a cluster,
and make sure all of our
changes are automatically
reflected in that cluster for
our inner development folder.
So let's stop this now
and close those Windows.
The next thing we
can do is debug.
So debug is a very
useful and handy tool.
We don't know exactly
what's going on.
We just want to stop
at the certain point
and make sure all the variables,
all the information is correct.
But how do we do that?
If we want to do this on
our Kubernetes cluster,
imagine that microservices
interact with each other.
Can we debug maybe interaction
between those [INAUDIBLE]
services?
Turns out that we can.
So if we completely
stop this session,
you can see that
developing in Kubernetes
not only allows it to
run, but also it debugs.
You can debug right here.
And click Debug.
So now, Cloud Code will call
an underlying scaffold domain
debug mode, which will convert
all of your needed manifest
and entry points to your
application into debug mode.
Support downloads between them.
Make sure port
forwarding is enabled
between the cluster
and your local machine,
and all the debug information
is being passed correctly
between the cluster
and your IDE.
So now, let's go to the endpoint
application again, hit Refresh.
And as we can see, the break
point has just been hit.
So now, this is not
my local machine.
This is my Java
Microservice code
running on my remote Google
Kubernetes engine cluster.
I can see what's
going on, what is
the state of the
application, how
do I need to improve
it or change it,
and what's happening right
there running on the Kubernetes
cluster, everything done by
Cloud Code, all the needed
changes.
So once I'm done, I
can stop debug session
and stop this develop
with Kubernetes session.
So to recap, we can easily
support Kubernetes application,
develop, create an
inner development loop,
update them on the fly, see
the changes in the cluster,
or even debug live in our
cluster with Cloud Code.
SARAH D'ANGELO: So to
recap what we just saw,
Ivan used Cloud Code for
quick containerization
of his application,
continuous development,
interactive
debugging, and we saw
some great advanced
language features.
We also saw how you
can use our explorer
as a visual representation
of your Kubernetes resources
that show you the status,
allow you to access terminal,
view logs, and view your YAML.
So really our goal is to
enable Kubernetes development
anywhere.
And so like we mentioned at
the beginning of the talk,
there are two paths for
Cloud Native Development.
So let's get into the
second one, serverless.
Cloud Run is our
serverless offering.
It shortens the path
between committing your code
and accessing your application.
Cloud Run auto scales your
application up or down,
even to zero
depending on traffic,
because it's request aware.
And you can run any
binary or language,
because you're deploying
using containers.
So really this is
modern development,
anyway you want to do
it, without the hassle.
So let's get right
into another demo
and see how Cloud Code
works with Cloud Run.
In this demo, Ivan's
going to show us again
how to containerize your
application, deploy to JCP,
view service status and
logs, and debug and develop
your service locally.
Let's dive right in again.
IVAN PORTYANKIN: Let's develop
and debug a serverless Node.js
application using Cloud
Code plugin and VS Code IDE.
As you can see, I have
just installed Cloud Code
into my VS Code IDE, and
the first thing I see
is the Cloud Code welcome
page with some key features
and resources.
You can install and find
Cloud Code from here,
from [INAUDIBLE] Marketplace.
You can just type Cloud Code.
You can easily find the latest
version of the extension here.
Great, so we installed
and found it.
The next step we'll be creating
our sample application.
We'll be creating it based on
the quick start samples that we
provide with Cloud Code.
So we can either
use this button,
create a Cloud Run sample up,
I use a command [INAUDIBLE]..
And command
[INAUDIBLE],, I'll just
choose Cloud Code
New Application,
say we need a Cloud
Run application,
and select Node.js
Cloud Run template.
Then it'll just offer
us to enter the location
and name of the project.
So we'll just accept
it by default.
I've already created this app.
So I'm going to close
this welcome page,
and open this
sample application.
This sample application
is a simple Node.js app.
It's open index.js.
Uses Express HTTP server.
Handlebars template,
[INAUDIBLE] the template
as necessary information,
and renders it
with the root [INAUDIBLE].
So it seems to be really simple.
It also has a Docker file to
containerize the application.
So now, let's try to deploy
it and run it [? serverless ?]
on our Cloud Run environment.
So again, we call
command [INAUDIBLE]..
Cloud Code deploy to Cloud
Run is our next command
that we need.
Let's click it here.
And let's check on
our login state.
It will list and
verify everything
needed for running Cloud
Run applications is enabled,
and list all existing
Cloud Run services,
in case you wanted to
deploy another revision
of this service.
So my select project is correct.
And you can change it here
if you want to, if you
want to select another project.
So let's create a new service.
As you can see, I have a
couple other services already.
And I can deploy a
new revision, which
will supersede older revisions.
Or I can even split traffic
between existing revisions,
but now let's just
create a new service.
The service will be a container
running [? serverless ?]
on a Cloud Run environment,
and providing our HTTP requests
and results via the endpoint.
So the service name
is regenerated for us.
Let's make it a
little bit simpler.
Node.js Cloud Run.
We will deploy the Cloud
Run fully managed offering.
Fully managed
Cloud Run will take
care of pretty much
everything for you.
It will scale up and
down as requests come in.
Make sure you don't
spend too much resources
and make your application
running in a truly a serverless
fashion.
Another option is
Cloud Run [INAUDIBLE]..
If you already have your
existing Kubernetes cluster,
you can use it for
Cloud Run as well.
You will just need to
install a little bit
of additional Knative and Cloud
Run infrastructure in there
that can use it as well.
Verification.
Two options here
allow [INAUDIBLE]
will allow us to access
our endpoint pretty
much from anywhere
without asking
for additional notifications.
It's usually good for simple
applications like this,
but for development
and real production
would probably require
some [INAUDIBLE]
set up [INAUDIBLE] services.
Revision container, image URL,
we'll just leave it like that.
This image URL looks good to me.
It will just keep our container
images in our GCP project.
And finally, the build settings.
We already have a
Docker file here.
So we can use it to
build via the Docker.
But also, we have
another build, which
is build backs,
already mentioned
in our Kubernetes examples.
So build backs understand
most common build systems
for Java, Node.js,
[INAUDIBLE],, and Python,
and can help you
build an image, even
if you don't want to write
[INAUDIBLE] own Docker file.
All right, it seems
like everything is here.
It's very much sensible
defaults are set.
So let's click Deploy.
So it starts building
the application.
We can click this button, Show
Detail States, get some layers,
build them, and now deploying.
Redeploying container to
our Cloud Run service,
it lists the project and region.
Everything was set by default,
and now it's deployed.
So it says deployed, and
serving 100% of our traffic.
And this is our endpoint.
[INAUDIBLE]
I'll open this endpoint.
Hopefully it starts
our container.
And now it's running with
this nice little image.
Perfect.
So once we deploy the
container and the endpoint
is running, once we
close this log window,
we need to know the
status of our application.
So we go here.
And in an extension we'll find
the Cloud Code Cloud Run pane.
If we open it, it's
called Cloud Run Explorer.
it lists all services that
you have in your projects.
The project is listed here.
And you can also change
it using this button.
But for the projects
we have four or three
different services.
So that's the one
we just deployed.
As you can see, a
green check mark.
It means the service is healthy
and it's able to run and serve.
Zero now serving revisions.
So we just deployed
one revision,
but once we replace it
with a new revision,
then now serving revisions will
go under none serving revisions
there.
While that's
serving revision, we
can right click, open
its container image
to verify where we keep the
image for that application.
We can copy the name of that
service, or we can view logs.
So once we, for example,
close our Deployment tab,
close our Output pane, we might
want to still review the logs.
So we can click here.
You can find all the logs.
This Log View pane
has a lot of filters.
We can do streaming logs.
As you can see, the
node just started.
We're using port 8080.
And we already
served some requests.
We can use it for other
revisions and other services
as well.
Great.
So we've done this
deployment, and everything
seems to be really
simple and easy
in a truly serverless fashion.
Our application that serves
HTTP traffic was just deployed,
and the Cloud Run
environment will take care
about scaling it up, down,
servicing it, providing
the load balancing, and doing
everything necessary for it
to work successfully.
But what if I'm not sure about
how my application is behaving
itself?
What if I want to debug?
I can, of course,
debug it locally,
but it's not exactly the
same, because the Cloud Run
application is running Cloud
Run environments on the Google
Cloud platform.
And ideally, I would love
to debug and to understand
the state, the status, and
everything that's happening
inside of that environment.
The Cloud Code has
you covered here.
For example, maybe I'm not
sure that the correct thing
is opening here when
I'm doing template.
But it's only happening in
my developer or production
environment.
So what do I do?
I just go, can then
[INAUDIBLE] again,
and say Cloud Code debug
on Cloud Run emulator.
Cloud Run will provide
a minikube based
Cloud Run emulator for you.
The environment will be very
similar to Cloud Run running
in production cloud.
So here we'll just keep the
service name, container image
URL.
Service name is slightly
different for us.
So we'll make sure we use
the same service name here.
It's just Node.js Cloud Run.
[INAUDIBLE] is the same.
Build settings are all the same.
And [INAUDIBLE] will be Cloud
Run run in debug [INAUDIBLE]..
And that's pretty much it.
Well, now I have to
click Debug button.
And as you can see, the debug
session has been started.
[INAUDIBLE] checks,
the minikube that
will be a base for
our cluster has
started in the special node.
We do the deployment and
build, and deploy in a local--
meaning a Kubernetes
emulated cluster.
So the image will run its
very similar environment
locally on your machine.
So it can debug and
understand its behavior
without having to deploy
to production environment.
The next step, many
languages require
you to specify where
exactly your sources are
when you debug.
So with that simple
application, the source location
is only one app.
For more complicated
applications
with many multiple models
or many multiple services,
you might specify your
source directories
in different locations.
But here, I am pretty sure
this is the correct [INAUDIBLE]
source.
So and it's all done.
My service and my
application is deployed.
And I have an endpoint.
Now, that's a local
endpoint for me.
So I am opening it.
So it's loading.
All right.
So the break point
has been just hit.
So as you can see, I
have all the information
running the application in
a same, similar, emulated
environment, as if it was
running on a Cloud Run
production instance.
So I have all the fields,
all the information.
I can step over.
I can just run application
and make sure it's running.
Great, so it's still running.
I debug it successfully.
I can add more features
and debug it as well.
And once I'm done, I disconnect,
and stop a debugging session.
And Cloud Code will clean
up this emulated environment
for us.
And we can then, again,
deploy in the next revision
of our service.
So close this, come back here.
So Cloud Code allows you to
easily deploy your serverless
application right next from
your code, see the results,
see the logs from
here, understand
what regions and what
traffic speed you have.
And then if you want
to debug and understand
a problem in your application
in a similar environment
to a production one, you can use
emulated Cloud Run environment
to debug and iterate
on your application.
SARAH D'ANGELO: So to
recap what we just saw,
we saw, again, that
quick containerization
using Cloud Code and more
continuous development.
We also saw some interactive
features for local debugging,
and more advanced
language features
that support Cloud
Run, and again,
great visual representations
of your cloud resources
using Cloud Code that allow
you to view the status and logs
of your services.
So we have a lot of
other great Cloud Code
features that we didn't
have time to show you today
that we hope you use,
such as our easy authoring
assistance using Cloud Code.
Authoring assistance allows
you to easily create and edit
configuration for many GCP
services, such as KCC, ACM,
Cloud Build, and
Anthos Migrate, making
it really easy for you to get
started with GCP services.
We also allow you to browse
GCP APIs from within your IDE.
So you can enable an
API, view the status,
and install client libraries,
again, all within your IDE.
And we have support for build
packs, which is an easy way
to secure production
ready container images,
no base image or Docker
file needed, which
is a great way for you
to quickly containerize
your applications.
So what we're trying
to say is, regardless
of where you are
in your journey,
Cloud Code has you covered.
If you're new to
Kubernetes or Cloud Run,
you can get started
with our easy
to use templates and snippets.
And we also have those
great visual representations
of your resources with easy
access to terminals, logs,
and status to make it
really easy for you
to get started with both
Kubernetes and Cloud Run.
If you're migrating
to Kubernetes,
we also can help you out
there with easy and fast
containerization of
your application,
and offering support
lets you seamlessly
integrate with GCP services,
making it really easy to start
taking advantage of a lot
of great GCP services,
all from in your IDE.
Or maybe you're familiar
and you're already
using Cloud Run or Kubernetes.
Well, we have you
covered there too.
Cloud Code can help make
your developer interloop
faster with interactive
debugging and everything
you need right in the IDE,
including support for tools
that you're already using,
like Helm and Customize.
So how can you get Cloud Code?
Well, Cloud Code
is available today
in the Visual Studio Code
Marketplace or the JetBrains
plugin repository.
So you can go on
your favorite IDE
and download and install
Cloud Code right now.
And we're always interested
in hearing your feedback.
We track our issues on GitHub.
And we're always looking
for feature requests, bugs.
Whatever you're
experiencing, we'd
really like to hear from you.
We do read them all and
take them very seriously.
So please, help us help
you, and share your comments
and feedback.
And thank you again
for joining us today.
IVAN PORTYANKIN: Thank you.